it's been a long time since we watched
any of epic rap battles and i was like
man
this one i bet it's gonna be worth it oh
boy
donald trump versus joe biden epic
rap battles of history well let's keep
politics out of this video okay
yeah definitely no one likes that
[Music]
politics
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
that is true
[Music]
uh
[Laughter]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
will you shut up man
that was great some burns in there man
there's some bars in there that was
great
dude
all righty
kudos to all involved man that was epic
it really was epic that is epic round of
applause
[Music]
i miss these guys yeah dude it's been a
long time
just even this this beat is all the
people that were look at all the people
that work on this man
it's a lot of work it takes a lot of
work please if you haven't subscribed
epic rap battles do it support them on
patreon they deserve it
it's creative stuff man gosh they had so
much material to mind
i've been following all the debates uh
the first i mean the second one was
better and uh you know even watching the
kamal harris
and uh mike pence one so yeah i've been
following all of this with epic rap
battles they're just having a lot of fun
and
of course their rhymes are great they
got so many lines to pull from
from everything that's been said over
the years but even just things that have
been said in the last few weeks and i
love
how they take advantage of that and
really include it here i do gotta say
i i really do gotta say a lot of times
especially when they're doing their
movie characters or tv characters they
seem to really
keep it equal the insults are always
like yeah who did win that one who did
win that one if i'm not
like just going off of the argument who
did win that one i don't know
if it's just because let's face it
i voted you know who i vote you're a
libtard you know who i really reported
all right it's pretty obvious who i
voted for i think it's because of my own
political leanings i really feel like
they gave a lot of really great insults
for
trump to use but i really felt like they
were getting very real whenever they got
to biden
yeah it seemed like they gave a lot of
like the great stuff
they had way more points for biden to
make towards
trump like they had the voice of trump
here
this is like what the things trump does
saying things trump would say but in
terms of like making real like political
points i felt like they were really
given most of that to actually
joe biden so i'm not saying epic rap
battles had a side necessarily it just
you know seemingly perceived wise it
seemed like they were leaning a little
bit more towards
their favor and biden well see now this
makes me cautiously
curious to go cruise the comments and
see if there are any like very pro-trump
people who thought that he
easily won this that's the way how
debate
the debates go if you watch any of the
debates everyone for trump thinks trump
won yeah yeah
so that could be the case right now
happening with us yeah i mean because i
agree with you i think that biden's
definitely had more of the bars and more
of the burns and i think that the trump
side i mean he definitely had the
character down he definitely had the
charisma down and i think there's also
just the you know trump says anything
whenever so in a way there's more you
can i guess factually grab
and you know turn into barbs from the
opposite stance
but yeah it was kind of a night and day
thing where like the good thing is
the trump parts of the song were still
really enjoyable really funny and really
well written but yeah when biden came on
it was like oh
you're in destruction this is like real
yeah
that's the thing is i wonder if that's
maybe revealing
of the creator's leanings because yeah
there's just so much
like punch to biden's bars i love the
part where the russian
team infiltrated each other interfering
oh god so creative perfect yeah yeah and
uh you know even though this is a wrap
form
i think i kind of prefer this joe biden
over the jim carrey one
i'm not a fan of i love jim carrey i
really do
but i'm not a fan of that jim carrey
impersonation
it's too jim carrey it's yeah it's it's
very
[Music]
the first one was all right because he
was a little bit like before he got let
off the leash but like the more it
happens i feel like the more he goes
down to the carry hole
for the first one i've seen in a while
this was like crisp like not missed a
beat in terms of just how fresh these
feel you know
yeah there's so many great lines in here
uh all the stuff about like
every lot of stormy daniel's wife
pulling the hand away
the opening part with epstein line i
think trump had a
a really great flow actually i remember
now on snl didn't he do some like
rap thing but when he was running for
president was it a
drake song or something like that like a
hotline bling or something
i think i think that's what it was yeah
i thought i thought the trump flow was
really good the biden disses were a
little bit
stronger but you know like at the end of
the day this is just for entertainment
you know
no this will decide the election this is
the society
should be one of these for every debate
there needs to be a camel at harris and
mike pence version with an interruption
of that why i'm surprised with the i
don't know when
this takes time to make obviously you
see the amount of people involved and
the second debate was only
last week and there was that big thing
where
uh trump had said abraham lincoln is
possible something about like
the possible exception in terms of who's
done more for the black community as
president right
then biden's called him abraham lincoln
and trump wasn't getting the joke
you know and that was uh there's like a
big part of the debate yeah that was
going around on twitter right
i was thinking that if they do a
follow-up for epic rap out they have
time before the election to do this
because the elections
like what next week if they have time to
do this
if they do a follow-up it would be great
if they did have abraham lincoln make an
appearance because they have had abraham
lincoln in the past with epic rap
battles so if they had him show up here
i think that would be hilarious dude do
it like the mcdonald literally do it
like the mcdonald's burger king wendy's
one where like wendy comes in surprise
you know
do that with yeah i think it'll work
perfectly yeah i'm sure by the time they
were making this and writing this there
was already so much other material they
couldn't mine from it
yeah this was like the greatest hits of
all the things
between the two of them but also there's
so many bits of news and quotes
i would love to see what lines didn't
make the song yeah i would imagine you
there's enough for force
what if it's on our patreon hope it is
dude go check out their patreon let's
check it out
all right guys well what did you think
about this sorry for having a political
discussion on this donald trump versus
joe biden debate even though it wasn't
politics that politically heavy out of
my waking life
all right guys well subscribe to epic
rap battles subscribe to the real
rejects if you haven't done so already
click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we got a video
up um hey hit that like button catch you
guys soon
[Music]
you